[Música]
mucha expectativa generó la visita del
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro a
Estados Unidos en donde se reunió con su
homólogo Joe biden muchos temas quedaron
sobre la mesa por ejemplo temas de medio
ambiente los mandatarios hablaron de
economía verde también de cambiar deuda
pública por una acción climática o una
propuesta hecha por el presidente
colombiano también hablaron para buscar
mecanismos para la construcción de una
reforma agraria en Colombia que los
campesinos de este país tengan garantías
de producción de otro tipo de productos
aparte de la hoja de coca también
hablaron de Venezuela hablaron sobre
este país suramericano y sobre una mesa
de discusión las sanciones que hay
puestas hacia el gobierno de Venezuela y
el regreso de este país a la escena
internacional si bien el presidente
colombiano aclaró que no es un mediador
si aclaró que Colombia está dispuesto a
intentar destrabar el diálogo en
Venezuela entre el gobierno del
presidente Nicolás maduro y oposición
todo esto para garantizar unas
elecciones limpias unas elecciones
presidenciales también hablaron de ese
cambio en el enfoque de la lucha contra
las drogas así las cosas entonces
después de esta reunión que puede uno
concluir hay sintonía entre Colombia y
Estados Unidos que está buscando Bogotá
en cuanto a fomentar ese diálogo y a
destrabar la situación en Venezuela y
pese al viraje del gobierno colombiano
un viraje en términos políticos este
país sigue siendo un gran Aliado de
Washington pues lo vamos a analizar hoy
en el debate de France 24 y para
conversar sobre este tema hemos invitado
a Jeff ramsey él es señor felo en el
Atlántico se conecta desde la ciudad de
Washington y desde la ciudad de Bogotá
la capital colombiana se conecta Daniel
García Peña Jaramillo él es profesor de
la Universidad Nacional de Colombia y
también es columnista del diario El
espectador en ese país nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de este
debate pueden dejar sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales estamos en Twitter en Facebook
y también en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f-24 y
a mí me encuentran en Twitter como
arroba santilogo no olviden también que
todos los contenidos del programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comenzamos entonces en la ciudad de
Washington donde tuvo lugar este
encuentro entre los dos presidentes el
presidente de Colombia del presidente de
Estados Unidos Jeff Gracias por estar
con nosotros aquí en el debate de France
24 y cuál es el balance que hace usted
de este encuentro entre estos dos
mandatarios americanos
Ah bueno Muchas gracias por la
invitación la verdad yo creo que fue una
reunión histórica o sea yo creo que hay
que poner esto en
el contexto histórico de que Qué
significa para tener un presidente
colombiano que fue en su época
guerrillero izquierdista no exista
reunirse reuniéndose con el presidente
biden en la casa blanca yo creo que eso
es una una muestra de de de de la
trayectoria histórica de del presidente
Petro y también es una muestra de la
importancia de la relación bilateral
entre Estados Unidos y Colombia Yo creo
que el solo hecho de recibir a Pedro en
la casa blanca es una señal de parte de
la administración biden de que más allá
del gobierno de turno lo que realmente
tiene peso en esta relación con los
intereses que tienen Estados Unidos y
Colombia y eso va a ser el enfoque de en
su diplomacia con Colombia
la impresión de Jeff nuestro primer
invitado en la ciudad de Washington paso
a darle la palabra a Daniel en la ciudad
de Bogotá Daniel Gracias por estar con
nosotros y también Punto de partida su
balance de este encuentro que tuvo lugar
en la ciudad de Washington
no concuerdo plenamente fue un encuentro
histórico Por las razones
que se había esperado mucho en Colombia
muchas muchas personas habían dicho con
la llegada de Petro iba a dar un
rompimiento con Estados Unidos y
discurso imperialista
volverse una nueva Venezuela y no
solamente no ha sucedido eso sino que
realmente de una manera muy importante
desde
48 horas del Triunfo de Petro el
presidente lo llamó siendo presidente
electo Recibió la visita de altos
miembros del gobierno de la vida
múltiples encuentros de diferentes
estamentos del gobierno norteamericano
es decir hay una relación mucho mejor
ahora más fluido ahora que lo que pudo
haber existido en el gobierno anterior
del presidente Duque Y eso también tiene
que ver con con una un reconocimiento
por parte de los Estados Unidos no
olvidemos de Gustavo Pedro fue elegido
popularmente
democráticamente y que la asumió el
poder después luego de una transición
pacífica del poder que hoy en día en
este mundo de del señor Trump en Estados
Unidos bolsonaro en Brasil y demás pues
le da Colombia una credencial una
fortaleza colombiana que creo que es
parte de la razón por la cual vayan lo
recibió también creo que lo que queda
claro de este encuentro viendo las dos
caras de la moneda es que Estados Unidos
recibe aquellos presidentes que sin
importar su tendencia política hayan
sido elegidos democráticamente y
elegidos y avalados por instituciones a
nivel internacional y por el propio
pueblo Washington no le Cierra la puerta
al diálogo y a conversar ha sido tal vez
una señal particular el gobierno de
biden y también del lado colombiano
también muestra que pese a las
diferencias políticas y enfoques que
pueda tener la política del presidente
Petro Estados Unidos sigue siendo un
país importante en aspectos a la hora de
tomar decisiones en la casa de nariño
por ser un país Aliado dos puntos que
pongo sobre la mesa Jeff y Daniel que
vamos a analizar más adelante hablemos y
era un poco la expectativa que había era
la sintonía que había entre los dos
países en cuanto a la temática de la
agenda a discutir Tal parece que sí hay
mucho entendimiento entre los dos
mandatarios sobre todo en temas
medioambientales que es por donde quiero
comenzar porque el presidente Petro
habló de economía verde y e hizo esta
propuesta de hacer un cambio de deuda
pública por acción climática que también
es un tema abanderado de la presidencia
biden Daniel comienzo con usted para
hacer la ronda la inversa
sí sin duda creo que ese es un tema que
como bien lo ha dicho para que el
presidente Pedro es es central el plan
de desarrollo que se está discutiendo y
que se va a aprobar pronto en el
congreso colombiano se llama Colombia
potencia Mundial de la vida el tema
climático está en el centro de la
política desde Perú el tema del Amazonas
sin duda alguna eh Como por ocupaciones
específicas y eso coincide con lo que el
presidente ha liderado
el paquete más importante de apoyo a
energías limpias en toda la historia El
de El John kerria encabezado un
liderazgo a nivel mundial de Estados
Unidos en en retornar a los escenarios
de del acuerdo de París de tal manera
que yo creo que ahí hay un tema es sin
duda donde Petro y biden yo diría mejor
Estados Unidos y Colombia tienen una
unos intereses
comunes y complementarios porque
obviamente Estados Unidos tiene unas
fortalezas en energías limpias que no
tiene Colombia pero Colombia tiene unas
unas riquezas y unas posibilidades
también de aportar a esta Alianza
Jeff de acuerdo a lo que dice Daniel
intereses comunes complementarios pero
viables en este tema medioambiental es
viable ese proyecto de un cambio de
deuda pública por acción climática ese
sistema de interconexión energética que
plantea el presidente Petro desde Canadá
hasta la Patagonia y todas estas
iniciativas verdes
Yo creo que esa es la pregunta clave Yo
creo que si bien Esta es una propuesta
ambiciosa de parte del gobierno de Petro
Es decir de de cambiar deuda a cambio de
proteger
las células amazónica yo creo que hasta
ahora no hemos visto
un mensaje claro de parte de la
administración biden de que podría ser
aceptado
por Estados Unidos sin embargo yo creo
que fue bastante notable la presencia
del secretario John Carrey en esa esa
reunión con presidente Petro yo creo que
carry como el zar de de biden en todo lo
que tiene que ver con el cambio
climático tiene mucha mucha capacidad de
tomar decisiones y yo creo que tenerle a
él en esta reunión no fue algo
al azar yo creo que eso fue al propósito
y demuestra que que es una área En lo
cual podría haber más coordinación en el
futuro lo otro es Venezuela yo creo que
vimos tanto de parte de la
Administración biden como de del
presidente Petro un mensaje claro de
interés en coordinar en Venezuela
tenemos sabemos que Colombia va a ser
anfitrón de una conferencia
internacional sobre Venezuela en los
próximos días y creo que es una
oportunidad interesante de de avanzar
una coordinación más profunda entre
Estados Unidos y Colombia en la búsqueda
de una solución democrática a la crisis
de Venezuela Jeff ya que usted trae el
tema de Venezuela a la mesa del debate
pues continuó profundizando entonces en
él y dejo un poco de lado el tema
medioambiental hablemos para tratar de
internet de entender Por qué en este
momento Estados Unidos tiene interés en
fomentar este diá en Venezuela en un
entendimiento entre la oposición y el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro porque
recordemos que en la administración
pasada en la administración del
presidente Duque en Colombia Estados
Unidos respaldaba esta política del
cerco diplomático y de prácticamente
aislar a Venezuela del sistema
internacional para ser colapsar la
economía del gobierno y fomentar ahí un
un cambio de gobierno y de rumbo
político ahora la mirada es
completamente distinta Colombia Está
tratando de llevar a Venezuela al
escenario internacional porque
Washington se mostraría interesado en
esto
Bueno yo creo que
es bastante obvio que la estrategia
anterior de de la máxima presión no
llegó a a
producir un cambio democrático en
Venezuela Así que no es solo Estados
Unidos que está buscando una estrategia
nueva para impulsar una solución
democrática a la crisis en Venezuela
sino la mayoría de de sus aliados
también
hemos visto en los últimos dos años como
un número creciente de países que antes
se habían reconocido a Juan guaidó como
el presidente interino de Venezuela ya
están empezando a reabrir sus embajadas
en Venezuela
están buscando Cómo seguir resaltando
las preocupaciones de de Derechos
Humanos que tienen sobre la realidad de
Venezuela
mientras buscan tener una relación
con el el gobierno de facto que es el de
de Nicolás maduro yo creo que la la
estrategia que viene va a ser basado en
utilizar las las sanciones la presión
para para verlas para ver esa presión no
como una una solución en sí sino como
una herramienta para incentivar mejores
mejoras democráticas en el terreno
Daniel su opinión sí efectivamente como
dice
la política anterior pues fracasó Hace
cuatro años Duque dijo que los días los
hombres estaban contadas de maduro y
tronco lo apoyó Y hoy no está ni Duque
maduro entonces hay un hecho contundente
Pero por otro lado también hay nuevas
situaciones de hecho por la guerra la
invasión de Rusia a Ucrania la situación
mundial adquirió nuevos todos los de
hecho fueron los pocos días después de
de la inversión donde el gobierno de
baile mandó la primera delegación a
Caracas para reunirse con con Venezuela
con el gobierno de maduro el tema
petróleo Por supuesto que tiene que ver
con todo esta nueva realidad y además
hay otro factor que es que es que es
fundamental que el tema de la migración
es decir si uno mira la los flujos
migratorios hacia Estados Unidos pues
cada vez llegan más y más venezolanos
por eso el tema de migración es un tema
que en la cual Colombia efectivamente
tiene que Mostrar como hay una
experiencia frente a los venezolanos y
hasta Estados Unidos le interesa primero
que los venezolanos se quieren en
Venezuela y y segundo que Colombia ayude
en este tema de migración Entonces yo
creo que hay una serie de factores que
tienen que ver con una una un interés
común tanto Estados Unidos como Colombia
me interesan la transición democrática
en Venezuela y creo que también a
Venezuela le debe interesar poder
llegar a que se levanten las sanciones
que ha sido
de lo que ha planteado el presidente
Pedro el día de hoy Daniel continuó con
usted porque aquí mencionan ese interés
de Estados Unidos los dos coinciden en
el interés de Colombia de Estados Unidos
de levantar o de tratar de provocar allí
un cambio a través de las elecciones
presidenciales que están ya
prácticamente a la vuelta de la esquina
están a unos cuantos meses y pues la la
campaña electoral está por comenzar en
Venezuela y también el gobierno
colombiano está apostando o por lo menos
el presidente colombiano está apostando
por que Estados Unidos levante esas
sanciones que pesan sobre el gobierno de
Venezuela porque piensan Es sobre el
gobierno no sobre el país como tal sobre
algunos funcionarios del gobierno aquí
al levantar estas sanciones no estarían
generando un efecto contrario Daniel no
estarían de pronto dándole más gasolina
para mantenerse en el poder a la
administración de maduro allí en
Venezuela y Colombia metiéndose en una
camisa de 11 varas porque estaría
también prolongando el tema de la
situación en Venezuela que esto conlleva
Pues a la llegada de personas a través
de la frontera la crisis que ya hemos
visto a lo largo de los últimos años que
no vale la pena pues poner en detalle
aquí
el presidente Pedro es un levantamiento
gradual de la de las sanciones no sería
algo unilateral estaría diríamos de
alguna manera paralelo de dos carriles
en la cual por un lado se irían
levantando lentamente las las sanciones
Pero por otro lado y simultáneamente se
establecerían los los acuerdos los
calendarios las garantías de tipo
electoral para que efectivamente no sea
una una acción que
que mantenga el estatus de de Venezuela
sino todo lo contrario Silva para
incentivar esa transición es no es fácil
No es que se pueda hacer
de un día para otro pero creo que es
realista entre otros porque lo mismo
Estados Unidos han dicho que esas
canciones están condicionados a unas a
las condiciones internas en Venezuela de
tal manera que yo que es factible es
viable y es necesario que se pongan las
los dos asuntos eso la mesa pero ahí
viene la negociación y yo no creo que
que realmente es es de esperarse que
Estados Unidos actúe sin tener alguna
garantía y alguna contraparte desde
parte de Venezuela y del gobierno de
maduro claro y también esto es un buen
Punto de partida y también mucho saldrá
de lo que sea conversado pactado y
concluido en ese encuentro que va a
haber en Bogotá donde van a asistir una
gran cantidad de cancilleres de
representantes de diferentes gobiernos
de América y de Europa interesados en
esta transición en Venezuela Y en este
también regreso de Venezuela le hacían
internacional y un poco restablecer las
relaciones con este país Jeff Yo quiero
preguntarle por esas palabras que dio el
presidente de Colombia en sus
declaraciones a la salida de la casa
blanca y fue muy claro en decir que él
no es un mediador Pero entonces a qué
está jugando Petro cuando está en la
casa blanca tomándose la foto con biden
haciendo
gestiones a favor de Venezuela Cómo
entienden uno qué posición está jugando
Petro
a mí me pareció muy importante esa
declaración porque es un reconocimiento
tácito
de de que ya hay un proceso de
negociación en marcha entre el gobierno
de Nicolás maduro y la oposición
principal representada por la plataforma
unitaria empezó en la Ciudad de México
en 2021 Todavía está en en marcha de
hecho las partes acaban de firmar un
acuerdo humanitario histórico el año
pasado y entendemos que las
conversaciones
siguen entre las partes en Caracas yo
creo que ese ese reconocimiento de Petro
de que él no es un mediador
es una manera de decir que lo que está
intentando hacer en organizar esta
conferencia no es
reemplazar el proceso de negociación ya
existente sino buscar cómo
un un empuje un un apoyo internacional a
a ese proceso para que pueda salir
exitoso en la búsqueda de una solución
democrática que pueda conducir a
elecciones libres en Venezuela el año
que viene Daniel y para ir cerrando este
tema referente al punto de Venezuela en
este encuentro de avanzar con otros
temas de esta conversación entre los
mandatarios usted como evalúa ese ese
liderazgo que está asumiendo el
presidente Petro en la región hay
algunos analistas que dicen que rivaliza
un poco con el presidente Lula da Silva
que también está intentando alzar su
mano y mostrarse como la cara visible de
la izquierda de esta Nueva Ola de
izquierda latinoamericana Petro está
rivalizando con Lula usted como lo ve
no yo creo que efectivamente son dos dos
liderazgos importantes Pero son
situaciones distintas Brasil sigue
siendo un país mucho más grande en un
escenario distinto Colombia tiene una
relación con Estados Unidos mucho más
vieja y mujer anterior
al gobierno de son dos
volviendo a la el término que ahora
complementario yo creo que exista uno o
el otro sin embargo Pedro sí tiene un
liderazgo que en este tema de Venezuela
es específicamente interesante porque
bueno tomó la decisión de reabrir
relaciones con Venezuela desde
restablecer de abrir la frontera
establecer Los embajadores etcétera y
por otro sí ha venido ganando una
influencia en el concierto
latinoamericano sin pretender a
reemplazar a Lula o hablar a nombre de
todos de todas maneras fue muy
significativa que la semana antes del de
la visita la revista time
a Petro común de los cien hombres más
influyentes del mundo y que fue
precisamente el presidente chileno
Gabriel Boris que escribió el perfil de
Petro reconociendo su liderazgo
reconociendo la audacia y también el
pragmatismo de tal manera que esa es una
muestra de que efectivamente Pedro no
solamente habla como presidente de
Colombia habla como un líder
latinoamericano con una agenda en
materia de medio ambiente en materia de
drogas en otros asuntos donde coincide
con los planteamientos de otros
mandatarios y yo lo que lo interesante
es que en América Latina tenemos
diferentes gobiernos de izquierda cada
una es distinto pero Buscar los
elementos comunes Buscar los elementos
de de alguna manera puedan
plantearse como como un bloque
latinoamericano que es algo que es
bienvenido y en el cual sin duda Gustavo
pecho está jugando un papel
significativo Jeff me parece interesante
ver desde Washington
lo mencionábamos al principio del
programa la mirada que tiene Estados
Unidos hacia América Latina tal vez no
es una de las prioridades de la agenda
pero hemos visto ya varios presidentes
pasar por la Casa Blanca del presidente
de México ha estado allí ya unas cuantas
veces también ya estuvo el presidente
Lula en Washington y ahora el presidente
colombiano Esa esa crítica que le hacían
al presidente biden de estar dejando de
lado América Latina dejar de lado como
siempre se le dice al patio trasero del
continente americano tal vez está
cambiando tal vez la presidencia de
biden y todo esto también de Cara a ese
posible anuncio de una reelección en
donde el voto latino Pues siempre es
fundamental
puede ser también un coqueteo con los
votantes pero también un redescubrir de
la importancia de las relaciones con los
otros países de la región cómo lo ve
usted
Bueno yo creo que es cierto que la
administración va a Irene ha prestado
más atención América Latina en los
últimos meses para mí obviamente eso es
una cosa muy positiva sin embargo yo no
estoy tan convencido de que eso sea
Simplemente porque Estados Unidos por
fin está entendiendo la importancia de
de América Latina como
socios en nuestro hemisferio sino
francamente creo que tiene más que ver
con
intereses geopolíticos yo creo que
Estados Unidos está cada vez más
preocupado por
la influencia de sus rivales
geopolíticos como Rusia y china
en América y está cada vez más
interesado en en por lo menos Buscar
cómo cómo defender sus intereses
y
asegurarse de que tienen una una
presencia
en los países de la región no va a ser
fácil pero yo creo que eso es un poco la
razón por la cual hemos visto tanto
interés en América Latina en los últimos
meses y yo creo que las reacciones
a las declaraciones de Lula con respecto
a Rusia en los en estos días
corresponden a a eso también sí que le
costaron prácticamente un llamado de
atención desde Washington le pidieron al
presidente brasileño baje un poco el
tono en cuanto a la relación con Rusia y
la guerra en Ucrania
y eso también marcó un poco un cambio en
el tono por parte del gobierno brasileño
en los últimos días pasó hablar de temas
un poco más domésticos Daniel el tema
importante para Colombia porque ha sido
un tema transversal para todas las
administraciones
presidenciales colombianas las últimas
décadas y es prácticamente uno de los
grandes motivos que lleva a un
mandatario colombiano a hacer una visita
a Washington y es la guerra contra las
drogas y aquí Petro pues ya sabemos que
tiene una postura muy fuerte en cuanto a
esto al considerarla que ha fracasado
todos las estrategias que se han
utilizado hasta ahora y plantea un
viraje en la estrategia Estados Unidos
Aquí copió este mensaje hay sintonía hay
una disposición de Washington de Buscar
combatir el narcotráfico desde otro
punto de vista
yo creo que hay una coincidencia
interesante Aunque todavía hay que
definir algunos de los aspectos
específicos por un lado No cabe duda que
estamos ante un cambio en el negocio de
las drogas ilícitas voy en el tema de
las drogas no es el mismo de hace 20 o
30 años De hecho en Estados Unidos la
cocaína colombiana ya no es la amenaza
principal de la salud pública como puede
ser el fentanilo que viene de China que
viene de México por otro lado también
vemos que hay actitudes en la política
norteamericana frente ponemos la
marihuana los estados vienen legalizando
la
inclusive el presidente del país ha
hecho algunos anuncios desde ese sentido
es decir hay un momento donde la la
realidad puede llevar y está llevando
efectivamente a reconocer que las
políticas del pasado para una fenómeno
del pasado hay que revisarlos para una
nueva realidad
que estamos viendo y de hecho el
gobierno de Bayron enlazar antidrogas de
Byron habló de una política igual
reiterado la política de una política
holística de de de de de de de no
quedarse exclusivamente en el
prohibicionismo y la represión que era
la característica anterior además que
esto tampoco es solo es nuevo de hecho
en el acuerdo desde el 2016 entre el
estado colombiano y las FARC se habló de
una en el tema de los cultivos ilícitos
los cultivos de coca de una una
modificación de la política hacia la los
desarrollos alternativo hacia
sustituciones de cultivos un acuerdo en
el cual el gobierno de Obama y de bailen
en su momento apoyaron y de tal manera
buena parte lo que está planteando el
presidente Pedro frente del tema de los
campesinos de darles alternativas a los
campesinos Pues de alguna manera retomar
lo que fue ese punto uno del acuerdo
2016 donde ya Estados Unidos había
mostrado su su acuerdo yo sí creo que es
un momento donde donde hay hay una
oportunidad sin embargo todavía hay
espinosos como ese tema La extradición
Cómo es el tema
de la de la transición de una política a
otra pero Son detalles que hay que
efectivamente
dialogar Jeff su opinión sobre este tema
de las drogas recogiendo un poco las
palabras que salen de conclusión de de
este encuentro Estados Unidos ha dicho
que reconoce que es necesario un nuevo
enfoque para hacer frente a este
problema pero Colombia llegó con la
tarea pendiente
mostraron su preocupación por el aumento
en el número de cultivos de coca en
Colombia siempre llegan con la deuda
pendiente los los mandatarios nunca ha
sido suficiente el esfuerzo de las
administraciones colombianas en cuanto a
la sustitución de los cultivos
Sí bueno por eso no soy tan optimista
como como Daniel yo la verdad es que
creo que hay muy poco interés de parte
de la Administración biden en pensar en
nuevas estrategias o un nuevo enfoque en
la guerra contra las drogas
Yo creo que la administración biden
sabe que eso es un tema espinoso y por
eso no la está dando
[Música]
prioridad en público pero sabemos que en
privado las autoridades estadounidenses
están cada vez más preocupadas por eh el
aumento en la cultivación de de coca y
en la producción de cocaína en Colombia
Eso no significa que que Estados Unidos
y Colombia no pueden trabajar en otras
áreas yo creo que la visita de hoy nos
está demostrando que la relación de
Estados Unidos y Colombia va mucho más
allá de la política antidrogas pero sí
creo que eso va a seguir siendo un tema
espinoso para para para ambos países
Jeff dentro de esos temas y dentro de
esas múltiples aristas de la relación
con Colombia y Estados Unidos está esa
propuesta del presidente Petro de la paz
Total qué perspectiva hay desde
Washington el presidente biden que ha
dicho al respecto
a raíz de este encuentro
de hecho fue muy interesante porque las
declaraciones de de Petro fue preguntado
sobre sobre ese tema y dijo que de hecho
no fue uno de de las cosas de la cual se
se hablaron en la reunión Yo creo que es
porque en Estados Unidos todavía no hay
un entendimiento claro de que esta
edifica la paz total todavía no hay
una socialización de de las estrategias
de la Administración Petro con respecto
a esa política y y queda muchas
preguntas abiertas sobre cómo el
gobierno de Petro realmente quiere
negociar con no solo grupos guerrilleros
sino con actores criminales y cuáles
implicaciones Podría tener para temas de
Justicia Es que para el entendimiento de
Estados Unidos es difícil de comprender
que un gobierno democrático tenga que
sentarse a dialogar con un grupo
narcotraficante con una guerrilla o con
un grupo delincuencial para poder
alcanzar la paz Cuando pues han cometido
algunas acciones por fuera del marco de
la ley Daniel su opinión sobre este tema
de la paz Total que pues como decía Jeff
no fue uno de los temas trascendentales
de la conversación
muy interesante épocas seguramente
hubiera sido distinto pero de todas
maneras yo creo que tiene razón todavía
muchas dudas en Washington también en
Colombia sobre Qué significa la paz
total Cómo van a ser los diferentes
procesos con los diferentes grupos de
todas maneras Me parece que un elemento
que sí puede haber sintonía es el
compromiso que reiteró en los últimos
semanas el presidente Pedro de
implementar El acuerdo con las que había
quedado prácticamente abandonado del
gobierno anterior y que había tenido
problemas también de comienzos de este
gobierno creo que ahí hay un punto de
de hecho buena parte de los recursos que
viene hacia Colombia en la llamado Paz
Colombia están dedicados a la
implementación del acuerdo pero sin duda
nosotros aspectos que va a pasar con el
eln con el clan del Golfo y demás sigue
siendo un una materia más de preguntas
que respuestas Y hasta ahora creo que el
gobierno colombiano también ha sido muy
cuidadoso en saber que es un asunto más
de política interna que es una un asunto
para tratar con los Estados Unidos
Daniela en ese orden de ideas viendo uno
los planes que tiene el presidente Petro
la paz total
ser un actor importante en estas
relaciones con Venezuela en esa
reinserción de Venezuela en el escenario
internacional fomentar el diálogo con la
oposición tratar de ser un líder a nivel
internacional fomentar este diálogo en
torno al medio ambiente de una política
verde para generar energía a nivel
continental son muy ambiciosas las
expectativas que se están marcando el
plan de trabajo del Presidente Petro y
ahora unos cuantos meses después de
haber llegado al poder se está poniendo
sobre la mesa si de verdad son posibles
realizarlas o usted la ve completamente
realizables en este periodo de cuatro
años es poco tiempo un mandato
presidencial en Colombia
sí sin duda y efectivamente como usted
bien lo ha dicho son propuestas muy
ambiciosas de
detalla no solamente y lateral Colombia
Estados Unidos sino desde ámbito mundial
por ejemplo cambiar la política
antidrogas no es un asunto Estados
Unidos de Colombia es una son los
acuerdos internacionales y lo cierto Es
que hoy en día los principales eh
Defensores de prohibicionismo no son
Estados Unidos son otros países como
china Rusia los países musulmanes en fin
hablar por ejemplo de cambiar la
política antidrogas a nivel
internacional es una meta muy muy grande
muy difícil alcanzar en el corto plazo
pero yo creo que en es un debate que se
tenía que abrir y el estado Está
abriendo esos debates está poniendo
sobre el tapete internacional debates
que seguramente tendrán su desenlace y
sus desarrollos mucho más adelante pero
yo creo que en ese sentido efectivamente
se ha puesto una una unas metas muy
grandes y por ejemplo esto de unificar o
de alguna manera darle
distinto pues es más fácil decirlo que
hacerlo pero es importante plantearlo y
creo que en ese sentido hay que
reconocer que Petro ha puesto en la
agenda no solamente bilateral con
Estados Unidos y todo el mundo temas que
el mundo Tiene que disfrutar y ya por lo
menos logró que Estados Unidos pues
muestra algún tipo de interés o esté
dispuesto a colaborar en alguno de Esos
planes tan ambiciosos me quedan un par
de minutos para finalizar el programa
Jeff quiero comenzar con usted las
conclusiones que deja entonces este
encuentro muy puntual este encuentro en
la ciudad de Washington Y qué podemos
ver más adelante proyectando hacia el
futuro en esa relación Estados Unidos
Colombia y le pongo una ñapa como
decimos en Colombia Venezuela
Sí bueno Yo creo que
esa reunión como como dije al inicio fue
fue histórica y yo creo que es una
demostración de que Estados Unidos sabe
que la relación entre Estados Unidos y
Colombia va más allá del gobierno de
turno Así que mirando hacia el futuro yo
creo que si bien va a haber turbulencia
con los temas espinosos que hemos
mencionado temas de de la política de
drogas temas de seguridad también hay
oportunidades de coordinación en todo lo
que tiene que ver con
Buscar una respuesta internacional a al
cambio climático y también
coordinación con respecto a la crisis en
Venezuela como como vamos a ver con esta
Cumbre que Colombia va a organizar en
los próximos días sobre Venezuela yo
creo que hay un interés de parte de
Estados Unidos
trabajar con Colombia
hacia soluciones duraderas Así que yo
creo que esta reunión fue un un éxito y
y va a venir más posibilidades de
coordinación y Daniel su conclusión sí
sin duda estoy de acuerdo Creo que está
emergió una una nueva agenda bilateral
de Estados Unidos y Colombia climático
sin duda los que hemos mencionado el día
de hoy el tema de Venezuela sin duda
alguna es fundamental y tiene que ver
con con este mundo turbulento en que
está Estados Unidos viendo la guerra en
Ucrania china cada vez más agresiva
etcétera como decía usted ahora el patio
trasero hay que mantenerlo tranquilo y y
Colombia que ha sido el Aliado más de
los Estados Unidos en los últimos años
con este nuevo gobierno tiene también la
posibilidad de retomar esa relación de
dos años y de ubicarse en este nuevo
contexto como una ayuda a estabilizar la
región Pues a Daniel y a jeffles
agradezco mucho por este análisis para
la audiencia de France 24 gracias por
haber estado con nosotros es todo por el
día de hoy Gracias por su sintonía y el
nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos haber estado con nosotros la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y de Giovanni agudelo y
la producción de invitados a cargo de
Tania Herrera siga con nosotros
[Música]